the candidates at the Ronald Reagan
Library showed a new sense of urgency
and energy you hear the fire on the
stage tonight you hear the fire in all
of our voices they clashed over border
security foreign policy and the national
debt and I want to be responsible
because I believe
the VAC Rama Swami doubled down on his
bombastic breakout performance in the
first debate I favor ending ending
Birthright citizenship for the kids of
illegal immigrants in this country Nikki
Haley who was boosted in polls and
donors after the first debate tried to
accelerate that momentum in sharp
exchanges with him and others especially
every time I hear you I feel a little
bit Dumber for what you say in Ron
DeSantis polling a distant second sought
to make up ground against the front
runner the seven candidates who took the
stage at the Reagan Library are vying to
be the alternative to the overwhelming
favorite Donald Trump in a party that
according to polls isn't necessarily
looking for one
missing was Trump who wields a
commanding lead despite facing 91
charges in four separate indictments he
opted to appear at a non-union Auto plan
in Michigan instead an absence his
Rivals pointed out Donald I know you're
watching you can't help yourself I know
you're watching okay and you're not here
tonight not because of polls and not
because of your indictments you're not
here tonight because you're are afraid
of being on the stage and Defending Your
record you're ducking these things and
let me tell you what's going to happen
you keep doing that no one up here is
going to call you Donald Trump anymore
we're going to call you Donald Duck
again and again Donald Trump is missing
in action he should be on this stage
tonight he owes it to you to defend his
record where they added 7.8 trillion to
the debt they went after President Joe
Biden and each other you know Ron you
talk a really good game about cutting
spending but you've increased spending
in Florida by 30 percent with less than
four months until primary voting Begins
the time left to break out of the
Republican Presidential pact is quickly
running out John hendron Al Jazeera Los
Angeles
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera